The idea of a machine that can read your mind sounds more like science fiction than actual science. After all, what could be more private and inaccessible to the outside world than what goes on in your own head? But in recent years, scientists have been coming closer to making this fantastical seeming idea into reality. They've developed brain scanning tools and methods that can interpret brain activity and from that activity. Decode many aspects of what people are thinking. in essence, reading their minds. So how does this technology work? How do scientists translate patterns of brain activity into thoughts?
能够读取思想的机器听起来更像是科幻小说，而非现实科学。毕竟，还有什么比你脑海中发生的事情更私密、更难以被外界触及的呢？但近年来，科学家们正越来越接近将这一看似奇幻的想法变为现实。他们开发了大脑扫描工具和方法，能够解读大脑活动，并根据这些活动解码人们思维的许多方面，本质上就是读取他们的思想。那么这项技术是如何运作的呢？科学家们是如何将大脑活动的模式转化为思想的？
What kinds of thoughts can they decode? How advanced are these methods? And what are the limitations? What research questions can they help scientists to answer? What practical and moral questions does this research raise? And where might it be going in the future? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between
他们能解码什么样的思想？这些方法有多先进？又有哪些局限性？它们能帮助科学家回答哪些研究问题？这项研究引发了哪些实际和道德问题？未来又将走向何方？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨
psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Kenneth Norman, a professor of psychology and neuroscience and chair of the psychology department at Princeton University. In his lab, the Princeton Computational Memory Lab, he and his colleagues developed new methods to analyze brain scans. They use those methods to study learning and memory by decoding people. thoughts as they learn and remember. He has published more than 100 research papers and his work
心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天的嘉宾是普林斯顿大学心理学和神经科学教授、心理学系主任肯尼斯·诺曼（Kenneth Norman）博士。在他的实验室——普林斯顿计算记忆实验室（Princeton Computational Memory Lab），他和同事们开发了分析大脑扫描的新方法。他们利用这些方法，通过解码人们学习和记忆时的思想来研究学习与记忆。他发表了100多篇研究论文，他的工作
has been funded by the National Institutes of Health and the National Science Foundation, among others. Dr. Norman also teaches an undergraduate class called fMRI decoding, reading minds using brain scans. And he has won several awards for his mentoring and teaching. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Norman. I'm looking forward to talking about this fascinating research. I'm very happy to be here. Thanks. in the introduction that the whole topic can sound like science fiction or even a parlor game for that matter to people who aren't familiar with it. So let's start by getting some basic grounding in the science. Can you explain in a fairly non-technical way how this works?
得到了美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）和美国国家科学基金会（NSF）等机构的资助。诺曼博士还教授一门名为“fMRI解码：利用大脑扫描读取思想”的本科课程。他因其指导和教学工作获得了多个奖项。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，诺曼博士。我很期待讨论这项迷人的研究。我很高兴来到这里。谢谢。正如介绍中所说，对于不熟悉的人来说，整个话题听起来可能像科幻小说，甚至像一种客厅游戏。那么，让我们从科学的基本常识开始吧。您能以一种相当通俗易懂的方式解释一下它是如何运作的吗？
When we say you're working on reading minds, what does that mean and what are the tools that you're using? The core idea is that different thoughts correspond to different patterns of neural firing in our brain. So if we want to be able to decode people's thoughts, we need to be able to pick up on, for example, the difference in the pattern of neural firing associated with you thinking about a strawberry or a frog or a tree or what have you. And so the way we do this is with MRI machines. And so when people talk about functional MRI, basically we're talking about tuning an MRI machine to detect brain activity. And the way we do that is by tuning it to detect levels of blood oxygen. And basically, the idea is that parts of the brain
当我们说你在研究“读取思想”时，这意味着什么？你使用的工具是什么？核心思想是不同的思想对应于我们大脑中不同的神经放电模式。因此，如果我们想要解码人们的思想，我们就需要能够捕捉到，例如，你思考草莓、青蛙、树木或其他任何事物时，神经放电模式的差异。我们实现这一目标的方法是使用核磁共振（MRI）机器。当人们谈论功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）时，我们基本上是在谈论调整MRI机器以检测大脑活动。我们这样做的方法是将其调整为检测血液中的氧气水平。基本上，其理念是
that are more active use up more oxygen from the blood. So if we've tuned the MRI machine to detect that, we can get a sense of which parts your brain are more active than other parts of brain. Right. And so this is a very indirect measure of neural firing, right? We're not picking up on the electrical zapping of neurons, we're picking up on this kind of blood flow correlate of neural zapping. And so it's really an open question whether the signal we're getting out of this specially tuned MRI machine is going to be too blurry to detect these sort of nuanced differences in neural firing or whether it will be resolved enough to be able to do that. And so that's sort of the game that we've been playing has been trying to figure out whether this imperfect carolid neural firing can pick up on these relatively subtle neural patterns.
大脑中更活跃的部分会消耗更多的血液氧气。因此，如果我们调整MRI机器来检测这一点，我们就能感知到大脑的哪些部分比其他部分更活跃。没错。所以这是一种非常间接的神经放电测量方法，对吧？我们捕捉到的不是神经元的电脉冲，而是这种与神经脉冲相关的血流变化。因此，从这种经过特殊调整的MRI机器中获取的信号是否会因为过于模糊而无法检测到神经放电中这种细微的差异，或者它是否足够清晰以至于能够做到这一点，这确实是一个悬而未决的问题。所以，我们一直在玩的游戏就是试图弄清楚这种不完美的神经放电相关信号是否能够捕捉到这些相对微妙的神经模式。
And to cut to the chase, the answer is it does it surprisingly well, right? And so the way that we do brain decoding is basically we ask people to think about one thing. So we can ask them to think about frogs, right? and we take a bunch of snapshots of their brain activity with the MRI machine while they're thinking about frogs, and then we could ask them to think about lizards. And we could take a bunch of snapshots of their brain activity when they think about lizards. And then we feed those snapshots, the frog snapshots and the lizard snapshots, into a computer program that has basically been optimized to try to find the differences in the patterns of brain activity,
长话短说，答案是它做得出奇地好。我们进行大脑解码的方法基本上是要求人们思考一件事。比如，我们可以要求他们思考青蛙，然后我们在他们思考青蛙时用MRI机器拍摄他们大脑活动的一系列快照；接着，我们可以要求他们思考蜥蜴，并在他们思考蜥蜴时拍摄一系列大脑活动快照。然后，我们将这些快照——青蛙快照和蜥蜴快照——输入到一个计算机程序中，该程序基本上经过了优化，旨在找出大脑活动模式中的差异，
sort of which brain areas are more or less active when you're thinking about frogs or lizards, right? That's what a pattern classifier is, right? It's a machine learning algorithm that is basically trying to find opportunistically any difference in the patterns that you feed it. And so if there's a reliable difference in the frog pattern and lizard pattern, it'll find it. So if you and I were both put into an MRI machine and we're, were told to think about frogs, would our patterns look essentially the same? They would look kind of similar, right? But not identical because you and I might have had different life experiences with frogs and lizards, right? And the way that our brain represents
即当你思考青蛙或蜥蜴时，哪些大脑区域更活跃或更不活跃。这就是模式分类器，对吧？它是一种机器学习算法，基本上是在试图机会主义地寻找你输入给它的模式中的任何差异。因此，如果青蛙模式和蜥蜴模式之间存在可靠的差异，它就会找到它。那么，如果我们俩都被放入MRI机器中，并被告知去思考青蛙，我们的模式看起来会基本相同吗？它们看起来会有些相似，但并不完全相同，因为你我对于青蛙和蜥蜴可能有不同的生活经历，对吧？而我们大脑表征
thing is a function of our personal experience. But the ideas that our experiences will have been similar enough that there should be some transfer. between my brain patterns and your brain patterns. And concretely what that means is that if you train one of these pattern classifier algorithms on the frog versus lizard distinction in my brain, right, it'll do the best job at decoding my frog versus lizard thoughts, right? But it'll still possibly be above chance, right, at detecting your frog versus lizard thoughts.
事物的方式是我们个人经历的函数。但其理念是，我们的经历足够相似，以至于我的大脑模式和你的大脑模式之间应该会有一些迁移。具体来说，这意味着如果你在我的大脑中针对青蛙与蜥蜴的区别训练了其中一种模式分类器算法，它在解码我关于青蛙与蜥蜴的思想时会做得最好，但它在检测你关于青蛙与蜥蜴的思想时，仍然可能高于随机水平。
The most striking example to me of similarity across people's brains was a former postdoc in my lab, who's now faculty of John Topkins. Janice Chen, when she was here at Princeton, ran a study where she scanned people while they watched the entire episode of the Benedict Cumberbatch Sherlock TV series. And then she had them just recall it in the scanner while their brains were being scanned. And she did this for a bunch of people. and what she showed, which was totally amazing to us at the time, is that you could train one of these pattern classifiers
对我来说，跨人大脑相似性最引人注目的例子是我实验室的一位前博士后，她现在是约翰霍普金斯大学的教员。贾妮斯·陈（Janice Chen）在普林斯顿工作时进行了一项研究，她在人们观看本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇（Benedict Cumberbatch）主演的《神探夏洛克》电视剧整集时对他们进行了扫描。然后，她让他们在扫描仪中回忆剧情，同时扫描他们的大脑。她对很多人都做了这项实验。她所展示的、在当时让我们感到完全不可思议的是，你可以训练其中一种模式分类器
to decode which scene of the TV episode a person was watching. So she trained it to decode based on my brain, which scene of the episode it was. And then she showed that it did an incredibly good job at transferring to other people's brains, right? So the code that's being used to represent a particular scene in this TV episode, which seems like a fairly fine-grained thing, appears to be common across people, which is not what we expected. FMRI has been around for several decades, at least since the early 90s. What's changed in recent years to make your work possible?
来解码一个人正在观看电视剧的哪一集。她训练它根据我的大脑来解码这是剧集的哪一幕。然后她证明了它在迁移到其他人的大脑时表现得非常好。所以，用来表征这部电视剧中特定场景的代码——这看起来是一个相当细致入微的东西——似乎在不同人之间是通用的，这并不是我们所预料到的。fMRI已经存在了几十年，至少从90年代初就开始了。近年来有什么变化使得你的工作成为可能？
There are two things that could change, right? One thing is sort of the quality of the signal coming out of the machine, and the other thing is, how we analyze the data. And so both those things have changed, but the main innovations that have made this kind of thought decoding possible are on the analysis side, right? We're much more sophisticated in how we kind of chew on and analyze the data than we used to be.
有两件事发生了变化。一是机器输出信号的质量，二是分析数据的方式。这两方面都发生了变化，但使这种思想解码成为可能的主要创新在于分析方面。我们在处理和分析数据的方式上比过去要复杂得多。
Some of it is just like computers are faster and people have developed kind of better pattern classification algorithms, but part of it is we've just sort of conceptually we approach it in a different way. And so just to illustrate that, say that I want to figure out which out of all possible animals you're thinking of, right? There are a lot of different animals, right? There are hundreds or thousands, right, of different kinds of animals.
其中一部分仅仅是因为计算机速度更快了，人们开发出了更好的模式分类算法，但部分原因是我们从概念上以不同的方式处理它。为了说明这一点，假设我想弄清楚你正在思考所有可能的动物中的哪一种。动物种类繁多，有成百上千种。
And so one way to approach that problem is I could try to train a separate thought decoder for every kind of animal, right? So I could have you think about bears and then think about not bears, right? And we try to find differences in those bear snapshots and not bear snapshots. And then we have a bear decoder. And then I could do the same thing with sharks and whales and beavers and, you know, marmots and what have you. And so you could get sort of one decoder for every kind of animal, but it's very laborious, right? We'd have to train, you know, thousands of decoders.
因此，处理这个问题的一种方法是，我可以尝试为每种动物训练一个单独的思想解码器。我可以让你思考熊，然后思考“非熊”，并尝试找出这些熊快照和非熊快照之间的差异。然后我们就有了熊解码器。接着，我可以对鲨鱼、鲸鱼、海狸、土拨鼠等做同样的事情。你可以为每种动物获得一个解码器，但这非常费力，我们需要训练成千上万个解码器。
and no one wants to sit in the brain scanner, right, for as long as it would take to train thousands of decoders. But the alternative approach is instead of training one decoder per animal type, we can think that animals have different attributes, right? They can be big or small. They can be furry or not furry. They could live on land or water, right? They could be dangerous or not dangerous, right?
而且没有人愿意坐在大脑扫描仪里那么久来训练成千上万个解码器。但另一种方法是，与其为每种动物类型训练一个解码器，我们可以认为动物具有不同的属性。它们可以是大的或小的，毛茸茸的或不毛茸茸的，它们可以生活在陆地上或水里，它们可以是危险的或不危险的。
And the idea is that we could train a different decoder for each of those attributes, right? So we could sort of take brain snapshots while you're thinking of big animals and small animals, right? Or land animals or water animals, right? And the idea is that the number of dimensions along which animals vary, right, is, you know, it's more than three, right? But it's less than a thousand, right? So if you think about like the game 20 questions, right? The reason that it's 20 questions and not 100 questions, right? It's because you don't need 100 questions to figure out what someone's saying, right? And that's another way of saying. The number of dimensions along which animals vary, it's probably on the order of tens or a hundred or something. So instead of training a thousand decoders or 10,000 decoders, one for every animal, you can train 10 decoders or 100 decoders, like one for every dimension, right? And the idea is that if you have like 10 of these
其理念是，我们可以为这些属性中的每一个训练一个不同的解码器。我们可以在你思考大型动物和小型动物，或者陆地动物和水生动物时拍摄大脑快照。其理念是，动物变化的维度数量超过三个，但少于一千个。如果你想想“20个问题”游戏，它之所以是20个问题而不是100个问题，是因为你不需要100个问题就能弄清楚某人在说什么。这就是说，动物变化的维度数量可能在几十或一百左右。因此，与其训练一千个或一万个解码器（每种动物一个），你可以训练10个或100个解码器（每个维度一个）。其理念是，如果你有10个这样的
dimension-specific animal decoders, right? You can ask someone to think of something, and then you feed that data into each of these dimension-specific animal coders, and I can think, oh, Kim is thinking about a big ferocious land animal that's furry and brown or something, right? And then that gives me a pretty good sense. Maybe it's a bear. Right. And so the core principle, again, the conceptual innovation is that if we come up with the right set of underlying dimensions and train a decoder for each those dimensions, then you can decode the whole space, right? I could, you know, the system that I just described to you is like a general purpose animal decoder, right? It'll tell you what the animal that Kim is thinking of, you know,
特定维度的动物解码器，你可以让某人思考某样东西，然后将这些数据输入到每一个特定维度的动物解码器中，我就可以想到：“哦，金正在思考一种大型、凶猛、毛茸茸的棕色陆地动物。”这给了我一个很好的概念。也许是熊。没错。所以核心原则，再次强调，概念上的创新在于，如果我们找到了正确的一组底层维度，并为每个维度训练一个解码器，那么你就可以解码整个空间。我刚才描述的系统就像一个通用的动物解码器，它会告诉你金正在思考的动物在每个相关维度上的位置。
sort of where it sits along each of the relevant dimensions. And that's probably going to be enough for me to guess what animal is. Right. And people have applied that strategy to, for example, like, which of all possible nouns, right, someone is thinking of, right? And the idea there is, again, the number of dimensions you need or like, you know, questions you need to ask to pinpoint what noun. Someone's thinking of. People figured out it's maybe a couple hundred. And so you can think of any noun as sitting as like sort of a point in a couple hundred dimensional space. And so we can look at your brain activity and figure out where your thoughts are in that couple hundred dimensional space. And that gets us very close to figuring out what noun you're
这可能足以让我猜出是什么动物。人们已经将这种策略应用于，例如，某人正在思考所有可能的名词中的哪一个。其理念同样是，你需要问的问题数量或维度数量来确定某人正在思考的名词，人们发现大约是几百个。因此，你可以认为任何名词都位于几百维空间中的一个点。我们可以观察你的大脑活动，找出你的思想在那个几百维空间中的位置。这让我们非常接近于弄清楚你正在思考的名词。
thinking of. What are some of the practical uses that researchers are exploring for this? One that's gotten a lot of media attention is using it to communicate with locked in patients, people who are not able to communicate with the outside world, but may still be conscious and thinking. Is that research still ongoing? And are there other practical uses people are interested in? My colleagues, Martin Monti, Adrian Owen, several others have worked in that particular situation. The very clever strategy they came up with was if you have a locked-in patient, they tried to come up with mental activities that they thought would activate. very different parts of the brain, right? So it is that the part of the brain that's activated by
研究人员正在探索哪些实际用途？其中一个引起了媒体广泛关注的是利用它与“闭锁综合征”患者进行交流，这些人无法与外界沟通，但可能仍然有意识并能思考。这项研究还在进行中吗？人们还对其他实际用途感兴趣吗？我的同事马丁·蒙蒂（Martin Monti）、阿德里安·欧文（Adrian Owen）和其他几个人在那种特定情况下进行了研究。他们想出的非常聪明的策略是，如果你有一个闭锁综合征患者，他们会尝试想出他们认为会激活大脑非常不同部分的心理活动。
thinking about like playing tennis, right, and all the movements involved in playing tennis is very different from the part of the brain that's activated by thinking about the layout of your house, right? And so it is that they wanted to come up with instructions that would elicit thoughts that were really different from each other, right? And then they would ask one of these locked-in patients to, like, imagine playing tennis or imagine the layout of your house, and they would see these differences, right? Basically, the playing tennis pattern would come to life when this person who can't move or speak was asked to think about tennis and vice versa for thinking about the layout of the house. So that's the strategy they've used there. And they've used that to very good
思考打网球以及打网球涉及的所有动作所激活的大脑部分，与思考你房子的布局所激活的大脑部分非常不同。他们想出了一些指令，这些指令会引发彼此之间截然不同的思想。然后他们会要求其中一名闭锁综合征患者想象打网球或想象房子的布局，他们会看到这些差异。基本上，当这个无法移动或说话的人被要求思考网球时，打网球的模式就会活跃起来，反之亦然。这就是他们使用的策略。他们已经非常有效地利用了这一点，并证明了人们——他们不知道这些人是否有能力遵循指令或做类似的事情——他们证明了他们可以，这显然极其重要。
effect and to show that people, you know, they didn't know whether these people had the ability to follow instructions or do things like that, and they showed they could, which is obviously incredibly important. That's a very far cry from having one of those patients, for example, be able to type with their brain. But the idea is this is sort of a general theme of how we've made progress in the field is that you don't need to do extremely fine-grained to code. to be able to get insight into what people are thinking. So you can sort of set up a scenario where these very sort of crude differences are actually informative about what's going on.
这与让其中一名患者能够用大脑打字还有很大差距。但其理念是，这是我们在该领域取得进展的一个普遍主题，即你不需要进行极其细致的解码就能洞察人们在想什么。你可以设置一个场景，让这些非常粗略的差异实际上能够提供关于正在发生什么的信息。
And so another example of something that we're trying to do in the practical domain that leverages these sorts of crude differences is neurofeedback. right. So the idea there is that we can take someone while they're in the scanner, right, and try to decode their thoughts and then use that to train them to do something better, right? And so an example of this that I really like is Megan DeBettencourt, who was a grad student here at Princeton in my lab, was very interested in how to train people who do a better job of paying attention, right? And so the idea is you're doing something. boring task and your thoughts drift, right? Or you're a truck driver, right? And you're spacing out, right? And that could be very dangerous, right? And you might space out and then find yourself
我们在实际领域尝试做的另一个利用这些粗略差异的例子是神经反馈。其理念是，我们可以让某人在扫描仪中，尝试解码他们的思想，然后利用这一点来训练他们做得更好。我非常喜欢的一个例子是梅根·德贝滕考特（Megan DeBettencourt），她曾是我实验室的普林斯顿研究生，她对如何训练人们更好地集中注意力非常感兴趣。其理念是，你正在做一项无聊的任务，你的思绪飘忽不定，或者你是一名卡车司机，你走神了，这可能非常危险。你可能会走神，然后发现自己
like in a ditch, right? Because you weren't paying attention to the road because you got tired. So it'd be really good to find a way to train people to do a better job of paying attention or at the very least sort of notice when they're starting to space out. Right. And so the task Megan design involved having to do this sort of very boring button pressing task where we showed them a display where there were faces on the screen and they were also sort of in a ghostly kind of way superimposed on those faces pictures of scenes. So people are looking at these composite displays of faces and scenes and we would tell them like just pay attention to the faces, right? And press a button whenever you see a female face and ignore the scenes. And we'd have people
掉进了沟里，因为你太累了，没有注意道路。所以找到一种方法来训练人们更好地集中注意力，或者至少在他们开始走神时注意到这一点，会非常有益。梅根设计的任务包括进行这种非常无聊的按键任务，我们向他们展示了一个显示屏，上面有面孔，而且在这些面孔上以一种幽灵般的方式叠加了场景图片。所以人们看着这些面孔和场景的复合显示，我们会告诉他们：“只关注面孔，每当你看到女性面孔时就按一下按钮，忽略场景。”我们会让人们
do this boring button pressing task, right? And so Megan would be analyzing their brain activity and using one of these decoding algorithms, she could figure out the moment that their attention started to drift to the scenes that they were supposed to be ignoring. And the reason she used faces and scenes is because we knew, just like playing tennis and thinking about the layout of your house, faces and scenes elicit really distinct patterns of neural activity. And that gives us like a very very high degree of sensitivity to the exact moment where people started to process the scenes that they were starting to ignore. And then because we're doing this decoding in the moment, right, in real time while people are in the scanner, we could change the display the moment that
做这个无聊的按键任务。梅根会分析他们的大脑活动，并使用其中一种解码算法，她可以找出他们注意力开始转向他们本应忽略的场景的那一刻。她使用面孔和场景的原因是，我们知道，就像打网球和思考房子布局一样，面孔和场景会引发截然不同的神经活动模式。这给了我们对人们开始处理他们本应忽略的场景的那一刻极高的敏感度。而且因为我们是在当下、在扫描仪中实时进行这种解码，我们可以在检测到这种不专心的一刻改变显示内容。
we detected this in attentiveness. And what Megan decided to do very cleverly is that the moment she detected with this real-time brain analysis that people were starting to, to attend to the scenes, she made the faces less visible. She made the task harder. And so the idea there is she's trying to sort of amplify the attentional lapse. So the moment that your brain activity starts to float toward what you're not supposed to be doing, she made it really salient to people that they were messing up by making the tasks they were supposed to be doing really hard.
梅根非常聪明地决定，当她通过这种实时大脑分析检测到人们开始关注场景时，她会让面孔变得不那么明显。她增加了任务难度。其理念是，她试图放大注意力缺失。所以，当你的大脑活动开始飘向你不应该做的事情时，她通过让本应完成的任务变得非常困难，让人们非常明显地意识到他们搞砸了。
So the idea is that if we do that, we're going to get people to notice, before they would have otherwise, right, that they're spacing out, right? And the hope there is that we would make them more sensitive, right, to these attentional lapses. And they'd sort of learn to detect that better and to be less likely to have their attention sort of float all the way off in the future. And she demonstrated in a nature neuroscience paper that was published in 2015 that training people in this kind of closed loop setup where you amplify their attentional lapses makes them better able. to sustain their attention over time, you know, which was a big advance. And I'll just mention as a sort of way of building on that, we started to run studies. This is my grad student, Ann Mennon, and we're collaborating with a vet Shalene, who's a depression researcher at UPenn,
其理念是，如果我们这样做，我们将让人们在他们原本会走神之前就注意到这一点。希望他们能学会更好地检测这一点，并减少注意力完全飘向未来的可能性。她在2015年发表在《自然-神经科学》（Nature Neuroscience）杂志上的一篇论文中证明，在这种闭环设置中训练人们，放大他们的注意力缺失，使他们能够更好地在一段时间内保持注意力，这是一个巨大的进步。我还要提一下，作为一种在此基础上的扩展，我们开始进行研究。这是我的研究生安·门农（Ann Menon），我们正在与宾夕法尼亚大学的抑郁症研究员阿维特·沙琳（Avet Shalene）合作，
to sort of apply this same technique to help people with depression learn to sort of unstick their thoughts from sad mental states, right? So one of the most salient symptoms of depression is once a depressed person starts thinking about something sad, they have a hard time unsticking their thoughts, right, from this sad mental state. They sort of ruminate and ruminate on these negative things. And so the modification we made to Megan's task is very simple, right? It's basically the same task I just described, except we made the faces sad, right? And then we told people to attend to these pictures of emotionally neutral scenes and make simple judgments about the scenes, like is it an indoor scene or an outdoor scene, right?
将这种相同的技术应用于帮助抑郁症患者学会将他们的思想从悲伤的心理状态中“解脱”出来。抑郁症最显著的症状之一是，一旦抑郁症患者开始思考悲伤的事情，他们就很难将思想从这种悲伤的心理状态中解脱出来。他们会反复咀嚼这些负面事物。所以我们对梅根的任务所做的修改非常简单，基本上就是我刚才描述的相同任务，只是我们将面孔改成了悲伤的面孔。然后我们告诉人们关注这些情感中性的场景图片，并对场景进行简单的判断，比如是室内场景还是室外场景。
But then we just told them ignore the faces. But what we see when we put depressed people in the scanner and have them do this task is that their thoughts start to drift toward the sad faces. And once that happens, they get sort of stuck on the sad face. And so what Anne Mennon did in this study is basically the second that we detected with these brain decoding algorithms that they were attending to the sad faces, we made the sad faces really visible. And so again, the idea is to make it really salient that their thoughts had sort of rolled away from the scenes toward the sad faces with the goal of making them more sensitive to the sort of moment when this lapse is happening. with the idea that they could use that to get better at catching themselves before, you know, their mental state has gotten all the way into this sort of pit of sad thoughts that it's
但我们只是告诉他们忽略面孔。但当我们把抑郁症患者放入扫描仪并让他们做这个任务时，我们看到他们的思绪开始飘向悲伤的面孔。一旦发生这种情况，他们就会被困在悲伤的面孔上。所以安·门农在这项研究中所做的是，当我们用这些大脑解码算法检测到他们正在关注悲伤面孔的那一刻，我们就让悲伤的面孔变得非常明显。同样，其理念是让人们非常明显地意识到他们的思想已经从场景转向了悲伤的面孔，目标是让他们对这种缺失发生的时刻更加敏感，
hard for them to get out of. And so we're running experiments now to see if that training process basically helps them unstick. So it sounds like it's becoming both a diagnostic and a therapeutic tool in a sense. And I'm wondering, then are you moving toward, say, identifying people with maybe disordered thinking or violent thoughts and then being able to maybe replace those thoughts with healthier concepts? Yeah. I mean, two things there.
并希望他们能利用这一点在他们的心理状态完全陷入那种难以自拔的悲伤思想深渊之前，更好地捕捉到自己。所以我们现在正在进行实验，看看这个训练过程是否基本上能帮助他们“解脱”。所以听起来它在某种意义上正在成为一种诊断和治疗工具。那么我想知道，你是否正在朝着识别患有思维障碍或暴力思想的人，然后能够用更健康的概念替换这些思想的方向发展？是的。我的意思是，这里有两件事。
One of them is that diagnosis is tricky just because, you know, I mean, this is something, again, I mainly do basic research on learning and memory. so I'm getting a little bit out of my wheelhouse now, but I think that, you know, I can say with some degree of confidence that one of the changes in how people think about mental health and different conditions, right, is that they're very complicated, right? Like, depression is not just one thing and it overlaps a lot with anxiety and overlaps with a lot of other disorders, right? And so the idea is that the people who have depression, right, that's diagnosed in some way, it's a heterogeneous group. and it overlaps with a lot of other groups, and that makes it sort of hard. People are working very hard to do this diagnosis, right?
一是诊断很棘手，因为这主要是我在学习和记忆方面进行的基础研究，所以我现在有点偏离我的专业领域了，但我认为，我可以相当自信地说，人们看待心理健康和不同状况的方式发生的变化之一是，它们非常复杂。抑郁症不仅仅是一件事，它与焦虑症重叠很多，也与其他许多疾病重叠。因此，患有抑郁症的人——这是以某种方式诊断出来的——是一个异质群体，它与许多其他群体重叠，这使得它有点困难。人们正在非常努力地进行这种诊断，
But it makes it, that's one of the most challenging things to do with brain data, right? Is diagnosis. And so it doesn't mean it's impossible. It just means that it's a hard problem, right, that people are working on. But I think that this space that neurofeedback belongs to of therapy, or just promoting learning more broadly, right, where you've got a group and they've got some particular way of thinking, right, like in depression, these sort of sticky negative thoughts and you want to help them learn to control these negative thoughts or to be able to pull themselves
但这使得它成为用大脑数据进行诊断最困难的事情之一。这并不意味着它是不可能的，只是意味着这是一个人们正在努力解决的难题。但我认为，神经反馈所属的治疗领域，或者更广泛地促进学习，即你有一个群体，他们有某种特定的思维方式——比如在抑郁症中，这些粘性的负面思想，而你想帮助他们学会控制这些负面思想或能够将自己
away from that. Then I think that these sorts of brain decoding tools are going to be very, very useful. I think they give us a really powerful window into how a person is thinking in a particular moment. And in ways like this neurofeedback setup that I just described, we can try to choreograph experiences for them that will help them learn to do things differently. And, you know, this applies both to clinical populations, but also like education, right? The idea is that, you know, what it means to learn a subject in the course you're taking is you learn to organize your thoughts, right, in a way that adheres to the kind of ground truth of how things are, sort of getting scrambled up.
从那种状态中拉出来。那么我认为这些大脑解码工具将非常、非常有价值。我认为它们为我们提供了一个非常强大的窗口，让我们了解一个人在特定时刻是如何思考的。通过我刚才描述的这种神经反馈设置，我们可以尝试为他们编排体验，帮助他们学会以不同的方式做事。而且，这不仅适用于临床人群，也适用于教育。其理念是，你在所修课程中学习一门学科意味着你学会了以一种符合事物基本事实的方式组织你的思想，而不是让它们变得混乱。
But to concretize this, like say you're taking a course in computer science, You don't know anything about computer science, right? And what it means to learn computer science is basically to learn sort of which concepts go together and which concepts don't. So you learn that if then statements, right, are a way of sort of controlling the flow of sort of what happens in a project. And four loops and while loops are also a way of controlling the flow. But, you know, variables are something different, right? And so there are all these new terms. You have no idea what you mean.
为了具体化这一点，比如你正在修一门计算机科学课程。你对计算机科学一无所知，而学习计算机科学意味着基本上要学习哪些概念放在一起，哪些概念不放在一起。所以你学会了“if-then”语句是控制项目中发生的事情流程的一种方式。“for循环”和“while循环”也是控制流程的一种方式。但是，变量是不同的东西。所以有所有这些新术语。你根本不知道它们是什么意思。
And you learn sort of like these terms, like if then and wall and four loops, go together. And these other terms don't. Right. You sort of learn what coheres and what's different, right? Or if you're learning about animals, right? You learn which animals, right, are dangerous and which animals aren't. The idea is that we can use these different brain decoding measures to sort of get a window. into what concepts people think are similar,
你学会了像“if-then”、“while”和“for循环”这些术语放在一起，而其他术语则不然。你学会了什么是连贯的，什么是不同的。或者如果你正在学习动物，你学会了哪些动物是危险的，哪些不是。其理念是，我们可以使用这些不同的大脑解码测量方法来获得一个窗口，了解人们认为哪些概念是相似的，
what things people think at a particular moment go together, and which concepts people think don't go together. Taking this computer science example, again, if we've got two concepts that go together and we look at some computer science students' brain and we see that the pattern of brain activity associated with those concepts are really different, then we know there's some learning to do, right? We want to, you know, devote extra effort to
人们在特定时刻认为哪些事物放在一起，哪些概念人们认为不放在一起。再次以计算机科学为例，如果我们有两个放在一起的概念，我们观察一些计算机科学学生的大脑，发现与这些概念相关的大脑活动模式非常不同，那么我们就知道还有一些学习要做。我们想要投入额外的努力来
helping them understand that these things go together. And so we can give them some, you know, lesson on how these things go together. And we could see whether that lesson is successful by scanning their brain after the lesson to see if those concepts that should go together elicit similar patterns of brain activity. So you don't have to take tests anymore, right? Your professor puts you in an fMRI and says, aha, you didn't really learn this. Right. So the reason that I was using this computer science example is that a postdoc in my lab, who now works at the computer company, Snap, Mayor Mechelam did exactly the study. So he took computer science students at Princeton who are taking introductory computer science,
帮助他们理解这些事物是放在一起的。我们可以给他们一些关于这些事物如何放在一起的课程。我们可以通过在课程结束后扫描他们的大脑来观察该课程是否成功，看看那些应该放在一起的概念是否引发了相似的大脑活动模式。所以你不需要再参加考试了，你的教授把你放进fMRI里说：“啊哈，你并没有真正学会这个。”我使用这个计算机科学例子的原因是，我实验室的一位博士后，现在在计算机公司Snap工作，梅尔·梅切拉姆（Mayor Mechelam）就做了这项研究。他选取了普林斯顿大学正在修读计算机科学导论的学生，
and he scanned them multiple times over the course of the semester, and he looked at the brain patterns evoked by different computer science concepts and sort of how similar or different they were. And basically what he showed is that he could figure out how well a student knew a concept by basically comparing the similarity of patterns in the student to the similarity of patterns in the teaching assistant. And if this student had similar patterns when the teaching assistant had similar patterns and different patterns when the teaching assistant had different patterns of brain, that predicted that they would do well on tests of those concepts. Right, right.
他在整个学期中多次扫描他们，观察不同计算机科学概念引起的大脑模式，以及它们有多相似或多不同。基本上他展示的是，他可以通过比较学生模式的相似性与助教模式的相似性，来弄清楚学生对一个概念的掌握程度。如果学生在助教有相似模式时也有相似模式，而在助教有不同模式时也有不同模式，这就预示着他们在这些概念的测试中会表现良好。没错，没错。
So what you just said, you know, you could use a brain scanner instead of the test is true. Of course, it's, you know, cumbersome and much more expensive, right? And it, you know, is much more cost effective to just give the person a paper and pencil test. I think that the point I wanted to make is that there are a lot of circumstances with brain decoding where, you know, it would just be easier to ask the person to say what they're thinking, right? Or to give them a normal exam question, right? rather than trying to do this fancy brain decoding thing. And I think that the situation in which these brain decoding methods really shine is, you know, there are a lot of scenarios where they're interesting things going on,
所以你刚才说的，你可以用大脑扫描仪代替考试是真的。当然，它很麻烦，而且昂贵得多。给人们一份纸笔测试更具成本效益。我想表达的观点是，大脑解码有很多情况，直接问那个人他们在想什么，或者给他们一个正常的考试问题，会更容易。我认为大脑解码方法真正大放异彩的情况是，有很多场景下，有趣的事情正在发生，
and it's not feasible to just ask the person what they're thinking. Like, for example, we know from hundreds of studies that there are really important things having to do with learning that happen when you're asleep. So studies have shown that if people learn, you know, they study something for a test and then they sleep and then they wake up, right? They actually like forget less, right? If they had certain kinds of sleep during the interval between studying and testing. So something is happening, right, when you're asleep, right? Your memories are getting strengthened or maybe they're getting reshaped. And, you're, you know, It's this incredible, deep, sort of cool puzzle to try to understand what exactly is happening.
而直接问那个人他们在想什么是不现实的。例如，我们从数百项研究中知道，当你睡觉时，有一些与学习有关的重要事情发生。研究表明，如果人们学习了某些东西，然后他们睡觉，然后醒来，如果他们在学习和测试之间的间隔期间有某种睡眠，他们实际上会忘记得更少。所以当你睡觉时，确实发生了某些事情，你的记忆得到了加强，或者它们可能正在被重塑。这是一个令人难以置信、深刻、酷炫的谜题，试图理解到底发生了什么。
But you can't ask someone what they're thinking about when they're asleep. Right. Because they're asleep, right? You know, maybe you can wake them up, right? And ask them, like, what were you dreaming about? Right? And sometimes people can tell you, but you only get the sort of fading whips of people's thoughts. But, you know, one really cool application.
但你不能问某人在睡觉时在想什么。因为他们在睡觉。也许你可以叫醒他们，问他们：“你在做什么梦？”有时人们可以告诉你，但你只能得到人们思想的零星碎片。但是，一个非常酷的应用
for brain scanning might be to decode what people are thinking when they're asleep, right? So if the idea is, you know, and people who built theories of what might be happening during sleep is basically that your brain is composing for you a kind of playlist, right, of things that it thinks it's important for you to learn about, right? So the idea is when you're awake, stuff happens and some experiences get marked as being important, right? And they get put in this playlist. And then your brain sort of loops through them when you're asleep. And as a result of this looping through, these things are marked as being important, you learn more about these things. Right.
大脑扫描可能是解码人们在睡觉时在想什么。如果其理念是——人们建立了关于睡眠期间可能发生什么的理论——基本上是你的大脑正在为你编写一个播放列表，列出它认为对你学习很重要的东西。所以其理念是，当你醒着时，事情发生了，一些经历被标记为重要，它们被放入这个播放列表。然后你的大脑在睡觉时会循环播放它们。由于这种循环播放，这些东西被标记为重要，你对这些东西学到了更多。
And we want to know what's on the playlist. So that's a great example of something that we can do with brain decoding that you can't do, just with asking. And so Anna Shapiro, who's a former grad student in my lab, who's now a professor at UPenn, had a brain imaging study. It actually, I guess in this study, she wasn't looking at when people were asleep. She was looking at sort of what people think about when they're just kind of spacing out, right? The idea is this sort of looping through concepts that were marked as important happens when you're spacing out when you're awake in addition to when you're asleep. And she wanted to get some insight into like what's on the playlist, right, of things that you think about when you're
我们想知道播放列表上有什么。这是一个很好的例子，说明我们可以用大脑解码做一些你不能仅仅通过询问来做的事情。安娜·夏皮罗（Anna Shapiro）是我实验室的一名前研究生，现在是宾夕法尼亚大学的教授，她有一项大脑成像研究。实际上，我想在这项研究中，她并没有观察人们睡觉时的情况。她观察的是人们在走神时在想什么。其理念是，这种循环播放被标记为重要的概念，不仅在你睡觉时发生，在你醒着走神时也会发生。她想深入了解当你
spacing out. And how does that relate to the learning experience you just had? And she used brain decoding and got this really cool result. It sort of makes sense that the concepts that people struggled with the most when they were trying to learn this new thing that she was teaching them about were the ones that appeared the most on their sort of mental playlist when they were spacing out, right? Which is very adaptive, right? You don't want to spend your time thinking about stuff you already know. You want to spend your time working through the stuff that you don't know very well, And she was able to get a very tangible clear evidence for this idea using brain decoding. Let me ask you a long-term question, which is whether the goal is some kind of a universal thought decoder so that there'll be an absolute lexicon of what we know thoughts consist of.
走神时，播放列表上有什么。这与你刚刚经历的学习体验有什么关系？她使用了大脑解码，并得到了这个非常酷的结果。人们在试图学习她所教的新事物时最挣扎的概念，正是那些在他们走神时出现在他们心理播放列表上最多的概念，这非常有适应性。你不想把时间花在思考你已经知道的事情上。你想把时间花在解决那些你掌握得不好的事情上。她利用大脑解码为这个想法提供了非常具体、清晰的证据。让我问你一个长期的问题，即目标是否是某种通用的思想解码器，以便我们对思想的构成有一个绝对的词典。
And is this science fiction or is this something that's in the realm of the possibility? It's sort of like decoding the human genome. I mean, right. It's a very exciting possibility. And I think we're very close to having some kind of a universal thought decoding. And, you know, it uses the principle I described earlier, which is that, you know, we think that thoughts lie in these, we call sort of low dimensional spaces, which is just like saying that you can ask, you know, a couple hundred questions to sort of zoom in. on what particular thing people are thinking about.
这是科幻小说，还是在可能性的范围内？这有点像解码人类基因组。我的意思是，这是一个非常令人兴奋的可能性。我认为我们非常接近拥有某种通用的思想解码。而且，它使用了我之前描述的原则，即我们认为思想存在于我们所谓的低维空间中，这就像是说你可以问几百个问题来聚焦于人们正在思考的特定事物。
And you can make a decoder, you know, for each one of those questions. And then we can do that now. And that's a universal thought decoder. But it doesn't work anywhere near perfectly. It's like a very blurry thought decoder. We can tell where your thoughts fit in like this 300-dimensional space. But there's like a huge cloud of uncertainty around our estimate of what you're thinking about, right? And with functional MRI, that has to do with just intrinsic limits on the resolution of the technique.
你可以为每一个问题制作一个解码器。我们现在就可以做到这一点，这就是一个通用的思维解码器。但它远未达到完美，就像一个非常模糊的思维解码器。我们可以判断你的想法在 300 维空间中的位置，但我们对你所想内容的估计周围存在巨大的不确定性。对于功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）来说，这与该技术分辨率的内在局限性有关。
I said earlier, right, we're not measuring the zapping of all the neurons in your brain. We're measuring this blood flow thing that's loosely coupled, right, to the neural zapping. It's both blurry in space, right? So we can't tell exactly which neurons are activating, right? Just sort of which millimeter by millimeter by millimeter cubes of your brain are most active. And it's also blurry in time, right? This blood flow thing that we're measuring unfolds slowly relative to the very precise zapping of neurons. Right.
我之前说过，我们测量的不是你大脑中所有神经元的放电，而是测量与神经放电松散耦合的血流情况。它在空间上是模糊的，所以我们无法准确判断哪些神经元在激活，只能判断你大脑中毫米级的立方体区域哪些最活跃。它在时间上也是模糊的，我们测量的血流变化相对于神经元精确的放电来说展开得很慢。
And so that blur is not something we're going to be able to fix. you know, my favorite example of this when I teach is there was, I think, in like, 2008 or somewhere around then, this Newsweek headline that's like, mind reading is possible, right? Which sounds terrifying. And then the subheading is like, people can now tell with 70% accuracy, whether you're thinking about pliers or a wrench. Right. And like, that's cool. But that's like not the mental picture that comes to mind when you read mind reading is now possible. And, you know, I think that should be kind of reassuring to people who are worrying, for example, about abuses of this sort of technique. And if I had like one practical point to make, right, is that there's just
这种模糊性是我们无法解决的。我在教学时最喜欢举的例子是，大约在 2008 年左右，《新闻周刊》曾刊登过一个标题，说“读心术成为可能”，这听起来很可怕。副标题写着“人们现在可以以 70% 的准确率判断你是在想钳子还是扳手”。这很酷，但当你读到“读心术成为可能”时，脑海中浮现的并不是这种画面。我认为这对于那些担心此类技术被滥用的人来说，应该是一种安慰。如果我要提出一个实际的观点，那就是
this enormous gap between perfect decoding and. above chance decoding, right? And so when we publish papers in scientific journals saying that we're doing mind reading, what I mean is above chance decoding? We have some insight, right? But for example, if you, everyone I think now is using these speech to text things on their phone. Yeah. You talk to your phone and it transcribes it. And the idea is that if the speech to text thing is wrong, even like one every 15 seconds, right, which would be like 99% accuracy in the words it's transcribing. It's super annoying. And that goes back to what I was saying.
在完美的解码和高于偶然性的解码之间存在巨大的差距。因此，当我们在科学期刊上发表论文说我们在进行读心术时，我的意思是高于偶然性的解码。我们确实有一些洞察力，但例如，我想现在每个人都在手机上使用语音转文字功能。你对着手机说话，它就会转录出来。如果语音转文字功能每 15 秒就出错一次，也就是转录准确率达到 99%，那也会非常烦人。这回到了我刚才所说的。
If, you know, people are thinking, when can we have like people who are locked in just kind of type their thoughts with FMRI? And, you know, I think people could and are actually working on developing successors to FMRI, right? that might be more precise, right, less noisy. But with current techniques, we're not even close to, you know, 90% thought decoding accuracy or, you know, we're above chance. So I think, you know, in some, we already have a universal thought decoder. It just doesn't work super well. If people tried to use it as like a product, they'd be really annoyed. Well, plus, then you need to have an MRI machine, right, which is hundreds of thousands of dollars and it weighs a lot and you're not going to have one in your living room like a television set.
如果人们在想，我们什么时候能让那些被“锁住”的人用 fMRI 输入他们的想法？我认为人们可以并且实际上正在致力于开发 fMRI 的继任者，这些技术可能会更精确、噪声更小。但以目前的技术，我们离 90% 的思维解码准确率还差得很远，我们只是高于偶然性。所以总而言之，我们已经有了一个通用的思维解码器，只是它工作得不是很好。如果人们试图把它当作产品来使用，他们会非常恼火。而且，你还需要一台核磁共振仪，它价值数十万美元，重量很大，你不可能像电视机一样把它放在客厅里。
That's right. But there are other techniques for non-invasively measuring brain activity like there's a thing called EEG, right, which is electro-ensopulography, which is measuring electrical fluctuations on the scalp, which is even blurrier than MRI, but it's much cheaper. right? And so a lot of the commercially available brain computer interface headsets use EEG. Right. And again, the idea is that you're not going to be able to type with your brain with EEG, right? But it's very feasible with EEG to detect like how attentive you are. Like are you in a focused or unfocused attentional state or even sort of relatively crude. brain decoding things like, are you thinking about a face or a house? You know, and people in my lab have used EG. So Nicole Rafidi, who was a undergraduate in my lab way back when, used EG to sort of measure out how much competition there was between different memories, right? So sort of how hard people were working to try to remember foreign language vocabulary. And the idea is that that's very useful
没错。但还有其他非侵入性测量大脑活动的技术，比如脑电图（EEG），即测量头皮上的电波动，它比核磁共振成像更模糊，但便宜得多。因此，许多市面上可用的脑机接口耳机都使用脑电图。同样，你无法用脑电图通过大脑进行打字，但用它来检测你的注意力程度是非常可行的，比如你处于专注还是不专注的状态，甚至是一些相对粗糙的大脑解码，比如你在想一张脸还是一个房子。我实验室的人用过脑电图。我实验室以前的本科生妮可·拉菲迪（Nicole Rafidi）曾用脑电图测量不同记忆之间的竞争程度，即人们在努力记忆外语词汇时有多费力。这个想法非常有用，
because that tracks pretty well how well you've learned something. So the idea is that once you've learned something, your brain zips right to it, right? And wrong things don't come to mind. But when you're still kind of uncertain and you're just beginning to learn, for example, a foreign language, lots of wrong things do come to mind. Right. So if we have have this sort of cheap and easy eG correlate, right, of the extent to which wrong things are coming to mind, that tells you how well you've learned something. And the idea is that there could be maybe some closed loop flash card system that uses this EEG correlate of how quickly and easily the memory is coming to mind to sort of know which flashcards to show you. So if it detects
因为它能很好地追踪你对某件事的学习程度。一旦你学会了某件事，你的大脑就会迅速反应，错误的东西不会浮现。但当你还不确定、刚开始学习一门外语时，很多错误的东西就会浮现。如果我们有这种廉价且简单的脑电图相关指标来衡量错误信息浮现的程度，就能知道你学得有多好。我们可以设计一种闭环闪卡系统，利用这种脑电图指标来判断记忆浮现的速度和难易程度，从而决定向你展示哪些闪卡。如果它检测到
there's a lot of competition from this EEG signal, then it'll keep showing you that flashcard. But if it sees that your brain is zipping to the right thing, which we can do with the EEG, then it'll know that that memory is, you know, it's cooked, right? You don't need to show that flash card anymore. So that's another important lesson is that there's a lot you can do with coarse-grained brain decoding. And the depression neurofeedback thing I mentioned earlier, that's, you. using coarse-grained brain decoding, right? Are you attending to the phase or the scene? But we think
这种脑电图信号存在很大的竞争，它就会继续向你展示那张闪卡。但如果它看到你的大脑能迅速反应到正确的内容，我们就可以通过脑电图做到这一点，它就会知道那个记忆已经“熟了”，不需要再展示那张闪卡了。这是另一个重要的教训，即粗粒度的大脑解码可以做很多事情。我之前提到的抑郁症神经反馈就是在使用粗粒度的大脑解码，比如你在关注面孔还是场景。但我们认为
we can do really powerful things with that simple distinction. And so I think that we've been playing with brain decoding for a couple decades now. And I think at the beginning we had this idea of like anything's possible and we'll just see. We'll use all of our fancy machine learning decoding algorithms and we'll see what we can decode. And now I think with appropriate humility, We know the kind of limits on the technique, and we can try to tailor the applications of the technique to the limits that we understand. Well, Dr. Norman, I want to thank you for joining me today and telling me about your amazing research. It's really quite fascinating. Thank you. All right. You're very welcome. It was fun talking with you.
我们可以通过这种简单的区分做非常有力的工作。我认为我们玩转大脑解码已经有几十年了。起初我们认为一切皆有可能，我们只需要拭目以待，利用我们所有花哨的机器学习解码算法来看看能解码出什么。现在，我认为带着适当的谦逊，我们了解了该技术的局限性，并可以尝试根据我们所了解的局限性来调整技术的应用。诺曼博士，感谢您今天参加节目并向我介绍您出色的研究。这真的非常迷人。谢谢。好的，不客气。和你聊天很愉快。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinemann. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinemann 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Kondyne。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。